how is Kamala Hassan as a director how
did he give you notes how did he let you
know to change this or that Kamal Hassan
is a perfectionist in the most beautiful
way I think he's the chaplain of our
today he is a guy who was who is
versatile creates things very
spontaneous and wants very specific
visions and but he'll sit down with you
a day before and really go and work with
you you know
speaking Hindi and Amin was prime I
difficult thing I speak Hindi by
speaking Tamil I never spoke down though
so way to go through it phonetically
very giving very generous to have a
legend soul so giving is is humbling and
an unbelievable Salman Rushdie is
calling the banning of the film in India
a cultural emergency what do you have to
say about
well it's interesting I mean someone
nurses film called Midnight's Children
and that's coming out in the next week
as well February first Salman Rushdie
was banned for as a law for you
know for Satanic Verses
however I think it's insane I think it's
absolutely insane because cinema is
about about helping society not bring it
back it's fanaticism that holds back
system Society so I think it's a
regressive thing that's going on right
now in India we need to change that when
we need to stand up for this because
this has to change you know I think what
I agree what was Russia to that quote it
was a cultural emergency that he felt
that writers filmmakers artists etc need
to keep our nerve and continue to work
no matter what I agree absolutely with
mr. Rushdie it is a cultural emergency
it's a wake up call to India to not
censor to say that this is important and
this is what life is about
art is essential fanaticism is all will
always be there where only art contains
the world
and lastly Indian cinema and Bollywood
especially have such an exuberance for
their fans it's like they are cv4 their
stars it's like they treat them as
royalty do you feel a great sense of
responsibility to what you say and what
you tweet and the messages that you
absolutely I think it should be everyone
who has any type of power whether the
Indian cinema or Western cinema I do a
lot of work in both but they work here
and there if your Twitter of your
Facebook if you speak it is we are the
voice you know if you've got a
personality use it use it to change the
world someone like them on the Sun is
doing that someone like Aamir Khan in
Bollywood is doing that people need to
step up and change the world because the
only people listen or the people when
they when people speak of personalities
when you've got a follower it is a
responsibility and a duty because we've
got listeners so let's continue to
listen and follow and create change
wonderful thank you very much